do you ever like get past that hunger in
them candy yep I don't know what that is
everybody talks about that feeling it's
like a have you ever been so hungry that
you stopped being hungry I'm like never
you tell that to a starving child
somewhere have you ever gotten so hungry
that you stopped be hungry no never
okay so we went to a cafe gratitude yeah
which it's good I mean it's decent like
but the thing is when you eat there or I
imagine when you eat like a lot of vegan
vegetarian type foods which actually
isn't it anyways I'll get back to that
later but you eat it and you're like
really full but then you feel kind of
empty it's about a hot guy inside yeah
yeah it's like a fake out like oh I'm so
full here's my thing with vegan food I
don't like it when somebody has me try a
vegan food and they say it tastes just
like a burger hey well that's that is
the wrong you're phrasing it completely
wrong you should say this tastes good
dot don't tell me it tastes just like me
cuz when you're alive and then I start
to hate that the dish morg cuz I
wouldn't never hated you if you you feel
like it lied to you yeah so your bust is
dis man what's this burger patty made up
it's made out of kale a lot of like
earthy beans and it has a really great
crunch to it because we you know we
fried it and you describe it to me it's
like your pick that sounds pretty
[ __ ] bomb I'm down to try this but
instead they do this this burger patty
is better than beef I need to have you
on the spot you know double expectations
in reality kind of thing yes just fart
hmm do I cuz I you know it's bleeding I
post food on my Instagram you know and
it's like it's dead animal there's a lot
of married until I go but no they have
like this appreciation for all things
that are living so they don't want to
kill a living creature that's person
perfectly fine by me Jesus ain't a dead
animal I'm cool with it as if they never
heard of somebody eating animal
like it's the most barbaric action you
you're eating meat my god you know what
I mean it's like then one henchman in
the medieval movies that's what they
sound like to me milord yo you ain't no
flesh of an animal ha ha ha what'd I
miss you barbarian you know that's what
they sound like thinking like they've
never heard of this concept before it's
like you know what we're we're beyond
that now we shouldn't be eating me [ __ ]
kill yourself how about that I
understand - you have your perfect your
beliefs are your beliefs
I don't hate on you for it and they you
know they come back with the vice-versa
but you're killing a creature yeah yeah
I'm killing the creature
people kill people all the time - all
right [ __ ] [ __ ] happens I do I'll put
it out like that call me a monster I'm a
murderer that kind of what we kind of
previously touched on earlier today it's
like the best way to kind of intrigue
somebody is by setting an example whoo
and if somebody's interested in it
especially if it's a polarizing issue
they will more than likely once you talk
to them you know they might ask you more
about yourself and in the exchange of
dialogue you end up learning a lot my
mom has been a vegetarian all my life
Buddhism no she grew up as she grew up
on a farm as a kid so there's like some
like or next to a farm yeah so there's
like some traumatization there I'm sure
she kind of made that personal decision
but she doesn't lock it over the
people's head like I grew up never being
shamed for it because my father eats me
and my mom so cherien should I register
all my life and so it was just kind of
this hybrid thing
and my aunt uncle they own a vegan
restaurant Oh awesome yeah but that's a
thing like they never say it tastes
exactly like this it's just good and for
Thanksgiving they do do this cute little
like this it's like it's a vegetarian
hand but it's in a mold of like a
cartoon Todd don't have it just don't I
have ham I think it is quite cute but it
feels like though it tastes good I don't
know what tastes like look at my hand oh
right oh it doesn't taste like it is a
good dish it's just good yeah so don't
hold him you may call it hand I don't
know what they call it don't put it in
the hand mold I think they might just
call it like a Thanksgiving dinner you
know what the great thing is I know that
Asian people have mastered the art of
cooking vegetables to the max yeah you
know like for example Indian food a lot
of it is vegan vegetarian very vegan
vegetarian friendly I love vegan I love
Indian food yeah you know I love that
[ __ ] but then you don't hear an Indian
guy it's going to taste just like
chicken me dr. Lurie is going to cut it
it is Buffett yeah you're you're going
to eat this and it's going to taste like
me know that you say it is good yeah
it's very good you know there's like the
two different types in my personal pain
and when it comes to veganism there is
the vegan that truly believes that they
don't want to kill anything so that's
how they live life on my Cajun okay
that's cool then there's the vegans that
preach about only eating vegetables is
healthier there's no where's the
scientific fact of it and the what I
don't like about people whether it's
vegan people or worse like people who
will just love only eating me is when
you research something only to back up
your points but you don't research
something for knowledge that's like one
of my big anoints like this is person on
my answer that just laid all these facts
which by the way were true in terms of
what they were saying but they don't
ever want to talk about the opposite
because it just proves what they're
saying and I think that's so ignorant
you know what I mean you need to
acknowledge the opposing side so that
you can't counter it reasonably yeah if
you don't do that it just makes you look
more wrong well it's just if I
a bunch of facts I can just google it
yeah and it's like do you know you're
killing an animal I mean yes you dumb
[ __ ] I've been knowing I'm Asian we eat
everything we eat the butt crack of a
[ __ ] chicken if you could say what
are you having one kneecap bellybutton
eyeball is the couch it's so good I
think it's just a matter of really
appreciating what you're eating you know
which I completely understand and I
think that I'm more I have more of an
issue of that like the amount of love of
animal protein that we eat the the
amount that we produce and how much we
waste is the biggest issue for me versus
yeah you know don't eat me completely I
just don't like people getting in my
face about it you know because you're
not gonna change me because I don't
think eating meat is wrong period and
the story I've seen the videos I've saw
the way chickens were handled is should
an egg that's why I only get cage free
eggs now you know but you're not gonna
get me to stop eating me you know like
well that's why you're fat no is that's
not why I'm fat at all it's on fat
because I like butter and pasta oh so
good yeah if you like come barging in
with a stick
ask people to listen or not as you're
yelling at them to listen to you do you
really think they're gonna listen to you
yeah even on the Instagram this one was
like you're a [ __ ] monster do you
know you're eating dead flesh and I just
wrote back
I'm a monster barmy what is what do you
want me to say I wonder what other
underlying principles people have when
it comes to not eating animals because I
feel like perhaps they feel like it
makes them a good person a better person
for not murdering animals but if we're
talking about being a better person a
good person being a jerk yeah also
doesn't make you a good person yeah I
know I do
wonder how strongly people feel about
themselves being a good person when it
comes to you know I don't kill animals
and I don't eat animal but you're an
[ __ ] but you're a jerk so I got I got
a person this is the cells true -
because if it's a morality aspect it's
like you really you suck at it
forgetting about the others better to
jerk
yeah you know what I mean like I ain't
like dude I don't make fun of vegans I
don't make fun of vegetarians I do it
like heartily you know where I'm like oh
you're vegan why do you why are you
alive but that wasn't what I was
thinking about that I see I was like
okay here's my story dude so I was super
shy asian girl right um and this one
stupid [ __ ] Korean chick named Shelly
Kim I will take that back Shelly I'll
take that back I hate her to this day no
I don't hate her I don't hate her it's
like embedded in my brain so I was a
freshman right and I was so shy I've
never seen a penis I never like like if
nothing